I like doing that I must admit I do I
like doing that right good evening and
welcome to Stratford District Council's
planning East Committee my name is Andy
Crump and I will be chairing tonight's
meeting and the purpose of the meeting
is to examine the priming merits of the
applications being presented today again
before we start the meeting somebody
said I look a bit better behind this I
don't Thank You councillor Barnes for
your Cowan was there any way before we
start the meeting and before we move the
screen again and can ask members of the
public to make sure their mobile phones
are either switched off or put on silent
because obviously there's nothing worse
than speaker being interrupted by the
theme to the Great Escape and could I
also please respectfully remind members
of the public not to shout out when
people are speaking however tempting it
might be as only registered speakers are
allowed to speak so I'd like to
introduce my colleagues at major nice
legal services Karen Tate I'm team
leader planners East in my role as the
impartial advisor to the committee I can
clarify any planning issues that arise
doing this I'm bound by the code of
Professional Conduct of the Royal Town
Planning Institute planning committee
members are not bound by the case
officers recommendation or by oral
advice planner
but we do take it seriously so thank you
thank you very much so we're moving on
to first item of the agenda which is
apologies for absence what do you get
any attack thank you
disclosure of interest any disclosures
of interest any correspondence received
tell us is going smoothing with pretty
swimming mix smooth at least tonight sir
soon soon comes minutes minutes of the
meetings held on 11th of July committee
that I thank you which is application
number 18 / 0 1 5 4 7 / / me the energy
reservoirs limited energy storage
facility why awards farm Bishop search
engine joke thank you the application
site is proposed energy storage services
is located approximately one kilometer
north of Bishops it's in turn and two
kilometers southeast of Harvard is
located in the Paris kind of sort of
Harvard the application side mark icon
read the would occupy a small irregular
shape filled with foxing naught point
four hectares which is currently used as
arable land war farm which contains a
number of large agricultural buildings
is located to the west of the site the
closest one is located the Farnsworth
farm foxing 200 metres on the site
Harvey chorus sites from the Special
Scientific Interest
lies between 300 and 450 meters to the
west and to the northwest and southeast
of the site so sorry for the application
site is bishops it's in turn cemetery
this is an aerial shot of the proposed
development as you can see by the marker
the pros development will be situated
bishop politics is to the rear this is
Bishop citizen Cemetery Woolworth farm
and also the lodges fishbowls late and
the managers house in the access to the
road is from Woolworths road which is
tarmac service and a private lane
leading from the B for fourth I want
gate and Road default as indicated by
the witness plan the application is a
variation application of permission 16
such as zero to five three five full
there for planning permission has
already been granted within the redline
boundary of the application side the
application is seeking an increase in
the number of storeys units from 8 to 12
situated to the center of sorry as
indicated on the plant approximately 10
meters away from the Chrysler slope
which released a bishop bowls light as
seen on the plan this is [ __ ] the
Chrysler slowed to bishops bowls like
and this is in words of 10 meters the
justification I submit to are the
African for this was a geotechnical
survey which highlighted that could be
pretended to the cracks if permission on
the original permission if it was
implemented full detail if furthermore
the African have also submitted in
relation to the conditions which were
opposed on the original application a
construction management plan noise
report accused it faints in detail
Landscape Management a maintenance plan
tree protection scheme and hard and soft
landscaping full details of the plans
documents and how they relate to the
previous conditions are detailed in
pages 19 to 20 of the committee report
this is plan shows a previous scheme
which has been approved as you will note
the application would see a reduction
years city buildings by that I mean and
I will go into more detail further on
this building would be removed and also
a number of the inverters and power
station was also be removed the approve
screening total fences circle 402 square
meters this application
seeking approval of a total density of
circa four hundred twenty eight point
four square meters this planner shows
the alterations between the approved or
is detainers on the right under set of
2016 for Mac tanning permission and the
Provo storage containers on the left the
subject to this application please note
the air-conditioning units on the
original scheme of 2016 have been
conditioned to be placed on the floor
and in relation to new storage
conditions containers they are proposed
to be on the side of the two containers
this drawing shows the approved power
conversion systems by this you can see
the proof our conversion systems in the
middle on to the side of the approved
containers the green and white areas
there these are the newly proposed Alvie
substations which we replace them
inverters on the proposal as you can see
these would now be situated to the front
of the storage containers please note
though that there is less of them but
they are more bulky and bigger than what
has already been approved
this is an elevation drawing of the pros
DNA a B and O cabin this is an elevation
drawer under the approve control ring as
you can see on the approved plans this
is where they were have been approved to
be situated the DNA carbon and the
control room thus there these are the
elevation drawings of the proposed new
DNA substation and the customers
substation these are hard sanded images
our proposal of what they could be look
like so examples of what the containers
will be looked like and paint your color
green and so forth as you can see
they're proposed for the DNA substation
just on here on the side the customer
substation there is going to propose
there and it is smaller in width and
diameter
these are aerial photos taken off the
site of the minute no building works has
taken place whatsoever as you can see
it's open possible lands and that is the
project road leading to all war farm
which would access the site these are
views in to be subsistence and cemetery
views of the cemetery are applicable I
will meet that as the case officer you
can see the site form the cemetery and
you can see it when looking into so vice
versa as you can see these are the
buildings within the bishop sisters in
the cemetery and this is views going
into the application site as well as you
can see the cemetery builder than to
your left
this is photos of visit bowls late taken
on the slope there is a significant
incline so bishop bowls later situated
beyond this tree
there is a significant in calling in
slope and views looking outwards and
bang which there are noted this is the
foggy landscape management plan which
has been submitted by the applicants as
you would note they are proposing to
implement a tree vault which is within
the red lines here and also additional
plant into the front of the site here
this is where a bit of distance and
symmetry would be subjected to
furthermore please note the acoustic
barrier is surround in all the
containers here the only thing that is
outside the key visa virus to the DNA
substations the left hand side this is
the details for the acoustic barrier and
it has been set over and proposed for a
condition to be set at 3.6 meters to try
and obscure and infused into the side
and that would surround the application
this is the hardest and earnest details
that have been submitted by the Africans
the acoustic barrier would be made a
fenced-off C insulation and so forth
would be put in between for the acoustic
noise and also the hard landscaping on
the road the polyatomic mouth would be
used during the construction phase and
then removed afterwards these are the
differences between the two prime
ministers of trying to subscribe and
that is the end of the presentation
officer recommendation is for approval
and in regards to the update sheet an
amended traffic margin plan has been
received on picture for within the plan
is welfare set of details where the
construction parking area will be
located within the red line boundary
thank you
I'll see ya
you've been here for you Tom's getting
some double Marcel you know the ropes
would you like a warning shot at
lacrosse yeah thank you good man far
away when you're already ok good even a
mr. chair good even committee back in
February of 2017 this committee made a
decision to grant permission for eighth
battery storage units on this site along
with the associated infrastructure and
buildings to enable them to operate this
cook this committee also added some very
specific and explicit conditions amongst
these is the positioning of the HVAC
units to minimize the industrial noise
impacts on the cemetery and the nearby
residential receptors many of which are
still ignored at this regard by the
reports you've seen the condition stated
that the units be placed at ground level
the condition is not to keep the HVAC
units off the roof as the report implies
but to keep them on the ground forgiving
the officers acknowledgement of the
challenges associated with examining and
mitigating noise where the developments
has not taken place
noise raport has still ignored
residential receptors which have been
built out notably the owners Lodge of
bishops bulb Lakes which wasn't pointed
out in the diagram with such an omission
can we be sure the cs9 is actually met
whether it be the green corrugated steel
of a battery unit or a painted fence one
cannot escape the fact that the wrong
surroundings of the cemetery will be
blighted by this industrialization and
now ten meters closer than previously
refused the traffic management plan is
not yet robust and contains numerous
inaccuracies which undermine the level
of confidence that can be placed in it
along with incorrectly quoting the beef
double 4-5-1 as a national speed limit
road it tells drivers to park up away
from the site and call ahead that gives
no instruction as to where the access
route is given as via the m-40 Junction
12 so unless they're parking somewhere
in Banbury or Warrick services there is
no where to safely park a 37 ton vehicle
that will not cause a danger pedestrians
or to or obstruct the traffic flow on
the B double for flight one with this in
mind also the parking of such vehicles
in front of the cemetery in the lay-by
there is not acceptable a significant
concern to us remains the risk of
disruption to a funeral service
the points proposed in condition four
seemed to reasonably cover the
situations which may arise
though what enforcement action could be
taken as such short notice is a worry a
person's passing is marked only once and
must not be disturbed this facility can
be built any day of the week on a final
note can I suggest a review of proposed
conditions three and eight since they
contradict one another thank you thank
you very much Thank You chair good
evening good evening councillor wonder
whether you can just advise whether the
applicant came to talk back to the
parish council about this increased size
of the proposal did they come to the
parish council and they explained what
they were trying to do did they consult
and engage with you so it's quite
interesting on this day they did appear
at one of our parish council meetings at
short notice
to the extent I had to get the Council's
permission from disappear because it was
not an agenda item they presented very
briefly the the upper diagram that you
see there and were requested to return
to the following council meeting which
we would be discussing your own agenda
as the application had come forward at
that point all was arranged they had an
agenda slot and subsequently withdrew
matter of hours before the meeting so we
didn't have the opportunity to fully
discuss this
catch the bombs this needs to be some
concern about defense in Paris gasoline
in the paperwork yeah you're coming down
I don't know do you mean the acoustic
very fence yeah which was the issue that
your balance don't want a second
question but can just be a bit more
specific what you're trying to find from
the counselor place cast aside
yes German thank you looking at detail
here it seems to me from your
presentation that you were talking about
the lack of the of detail within the
traffic management plan am i right there
yeah fine now according to this update
sheet it says an amended traffic
management plan has been received
what detail has the Parish Council had
for that that plan doesn't seem to me
chairman adequate time to study some an
important detail of this application
that's a fair point can we talk about
that in the divine to a points of
clarification
thank you can sir any further questions
thank you
yeah we found a slight change in the
running order
the cat was no longer object and he's
now speaking as the ward member so if
you could be oval this is one second
cancer kettle we could go to the agent
she's Sarah Hitchcock Hitchcock's
yes Kristen one in the middle
I'm sure the vans over great right good
evening and thank you for the
opportunity to speak to you regarding
this application two very conditions
associated with Panna provision one six
four slash zero two five three five my
name is Sarah Hitchcock
I'm director of development at an SK
limited and we are the applicants for
this scheme we fully support the offices
recommendation to approve the planning
application which is followed lengthy
discussions and close working with
offices over the last six months the
previous application was approved by
members in January 2017 this proposal
seeks minor alterations to the layout of
the scheme but keeps the overall
capacity the same as originally approved
therefore the principle of this
development has been established and
it's not a consideration in the
determination of this application we are
aware that there have been a number of
objections to this application and we
would like to clarify the changes that
will occur as part of the revised game
the number of containers has increased
from 8 to 12 however unlike the approved
scheme additional equipment is housed
within the containers reducing the a
rural development we have also reverted
the layout back in line with the
approved scheme positioning the
containers on the northern boundary
which also follow the site boundary and
we have ensured that there are gaps
between the containers to alleviate the
solid block appearance a site
investigation identified areas of
potential instability on the northern
boundary of the site and thus the
containers have been moved approximately
10 meters south whilst we acknowledge
this brings the containers fair the
south the mitigation measures proposed
have been increased over and above what
was previously approved the acoustic
fence will now be at a height of 3.6
meters and painted green this increase
in height has been requested by the
council's environmental health officer
and an ESCO more than happy to agree to
this on the provision of a three points
meet offense the environmental health of
thir has no objections and is not
consider it to have any further impact
to that which was previously approved
residents have concerns regarding the
air-conditioning units in terms of their
location
this proposal sees the units located on
the fires of the containers rather than
on the top thus reducing the aerial
noise impact this has been addressed in
the noise impact assessment which has
been considered by the council's
Environmental Health Officer who has no
objections the acoustic fence will also
provide screening masive the equipment
will be enclosed by the fence and the
tallest piece of apparatus will not be
visible only the DNA substation is
rickie to the outside the fence however
this is located furthest away from the
cemetery and in the same location as
previously approved
although revisions are proposed to the
scheme it has been demonstrated that
there will be no greater impact even
above what is previously been approved
in terms of noise and visual impacts
although the density the development has
increased slightly this is marginal as
the redesign will not be visible we have
also agreed to plant additional
landscaping around the perimeter of the
fight to aid in reducing visual impact
we have addressed the issues raised by
both parish councils and off-site
parking is now illustrated in the
traffic management plan discussions are
ongoing with a cemetery manager to
ensure that minimal disruption occurs
during the construction phase and ESCO
have worked with the local planning
authority to overcome the issues that
arose through the refused variation
application previously and it is
considered that a revised scheme fully
addresses any previous concerns ashamed
by the officers recommendation to
approve the scheme the proposal would
provide significant public benefits
while supporting renewable energy
developments it is therefore
respectfully requested the officers
recommendation be supported in your
decision today thank you thank you chair
and good evening I've actually just got
two questions I'd like to pose if I may
number one is the reason for withdrawal
in attending at the parish count
and number two you mentioned in your
presentation about minor amendments and
slightly increasing the site can you
explain what you're proposing is a 50%
increase in the containers that's how my
maths works from 8 to 12 can you just
explain how 50% more is a minor
amendment or a slight increase so
firstly we can only apologize for not
being able to attend the meeting that
was requested from the parish council
unfortunately it was just purely down to
a thickness that we had and we
subsequently said that we would return
quite happily or hold a public
consultation unfortunately we were
formed that it was then summer recess
and we were unable to then hold a
separate meeting so we have apologized
we would have preferred obviously to
attend the meeting it was just purely
from thickness and on the scheme itself
we do acknowledge that we have increased
the number of containers there are
several reasons behind that but overall
we think that the the land has
physically taken up by the development
which includes both the containers the
Alvey substations the DNA substation
it's increased very very slightly and
that's where we believe that actually
the overall amendments to the schema
very minor yeah yes thank you Sharon
we're told that the number of storage
units will increase from 8 to 12 I don't
think those and looking at the design of
the new impact units there could be some
impact
what is the applicant done to assess
that impact in its representation to us
or the parish council to purely assess
the impact of increasing the number of
containers
yeah say the reason why we've put in
more containers just to give it a little
bit of additional information so uh
nesco got a lot of experience in this
industry we speak regularly to the likes
of Bayes and off gem and National Grid
and we understand what is needed to
optimize the performance of the storage
unit and the original developers
wouldn't have understood the kind of
latest technological developments so
that's essentially why the containers
have increased from 812
although the capacity of stayed at 15
megawatts what we've tried to do to help
with the mitigation is we've obviously
had a similar pattern to what was
previously approved we've had it quite
close as close as we can to the northern
boundary or they restricted by the
geotechnical investigation our we've
ensured that the fence is now three
point six meters high which means that
the entire development is enclosed in
the fence and you might be able to see a
tall building first encase the bars
really with regards to the safety of the
units with regards to matters of far or
other forms of matters going wrong
within the units what precautions you're
taking the fire brigade and getting on
something so we obviously take fire very
seriously and the containers themselves
have actually got a fire suppression
system built in and so I can't show you
any photos of inside the containers but
it's got infrastructure inside it
already which means that if anything
were to happen the whole container would
effectively lock itself includes itself
and the fire suppression system would
turn on within 30 seconds and that would
contain any potential fire issues than
like I think we've covered yeah isn't
that one before come to you caravans is
acoustic fencing obviously we know the
material and what fire suppressant
abilities will that have is us would
that help as well I don't think because
the fire suppression system is contained
within that container it wouldn't spread
any further than that in fact applied I
think as part of the case offices report
it's actually outside of the fence you
can see the little the little circles
represent the proposed
trees they were intending to plant so
hopefully that gives you a better idea
yeah I've got the questions to do with
the traffic management plan obviously it
was a light revision and just wondered
reasons for that it was a factual areas
that the parish counselor pointed out on
which so I'm trying to speak yes under
what undermines a bit you know if there
are areas of the wrong Junction and the
wrong road and how much care and
attention has been given to the traffic
management plan yes so again we take
health and safety incredibly seriously
an ESCO we've got Ross the Gold Award to
pre back as part of the traffic
management plan it's just part of an
indicative scheme I ignored they may
have been some areas which now mean
right we've kind of progressed that
traffic management plan as we've had
further discussions with case officer on
the back of some of the comments that
were received and that's the reason for
the change in the parking that we had
and also we engaged with the cemetery
manager
we obviously acknowledge that it's
important to work with the local
community during construction we have
absolutely no intention of being
disrespectful at all and we will be
working closely with the cemetery
manager during construction phase okay
thank you
right thank you please again and we'll
move on to cancer the kettle is the
substitute for wood member and what a
fine substitute you've got five minutes
when you're ready cast the kettle Thank
You mr. chairman committee members this
abrogation adjacent to a cemetery a
chapel a fishing lake and a farm yard
who has no place in the open countryside
it's difficult to conjecture a less
suitable venture venue however we are
where we are we have eight units
approved protected by relatively low
acoustic fence and some landscaping in
February the applicant having bought the
site made an application to increase the
number of units by 50% removing any
acoustic protection for the immediate
neighbors fishermen and most importantly
visits to the cemetery be it for a
funeral or to visit the graves of loved
ones including the graves of those
children taken too early the application
was refused by this committee the reason
for this committee's refusal for them
iteration fall under policies cs5 and
cs9 firstly and I quote the new design
layout orientation increase in the
number of units and significant Ambika
amplification the overall density of the
site will result in an unwarranted and
unjustified intensification and
urbanization of the site this is exist
as a stated by the site's location
adjacent the bishops exchange and
cemetery and the view into the site by
visitors to Cemetery
that application ladies and gentlemen
was for Tet 12 units this application as
we know is for an identical 12 units on
an identical site than in addition it's
now surrounded by a 3.6 meter that's 12
foot solid acoustic fence whilst the
fence is necessary for acoustic reasons
to protect the cemetery given its
proximity to the cemetery in its Chapel
the impact of the solid wall will
emphasize the extraordinary nature of
this industrial application the
sensitive rural setting its impact by
that wall will be worse than the one
this committee refused six months ago
the case officer acknowledges this
impact when he states the result would
be more condensed and the news the new
LV stations are larger and more dominant
than the previous approved inverters the
report also acknowledges that no
assessment has been made on the impact
of this development on the 21 fishing
lodges which for those who view recall
when the first application came up were
not addressed by that case officer at
all or by that application why not why
is it not been addressed at this stage
the the dismissal approved lodges have
yet to be built ignores the personal
circumstances the resident which I'm not
at liberty to discuss in a public forum
the permissions exist and form passed
the lakes business plan for the future
the applicant has been has been given
consider also that applicant has spent
considerable songs and effort improve
the environmental setting of the lakes
which are now proving to be great
commercial success why for the future of
this business be put at jeopardy by
allowing this uncor for expansion along
with its fortress like ramparts further
the units are going to be moved close to
the cemetery than on the approved
application because the ground on the
original location is not sufficiently
stable is that a reason to allow this
industrial application to have a greater
impact on the cemetery than they weren't
one that you envisaged some three years
ago the refusal noticed specifically
refer to the impact the residence of the
bishop spell lake
this is February the nearest house on
the site yet acoustic report ignores
this home it ignores the future impact
from the already 21 approved lodgers it
refers to houses and Ruppert cattle
drive but ignores the 31 houses in the
recently developed mono green why
because the acoustic report could not
have been carried out on and his site
based work if they had they would have
noted Steen conveniently closed houses
and fishing lodges they did not can we
as a council to accept a report that
incorrectly refers to rupert cattle
drive being the nearest houses when in
fact it isn't it's marleau green it
ignored the bishops bold lodge why
because they don't haven't recognized
itself ladies and gentlemen this
application is a significant increase on
what was approved as you recognize last
time it's got a 12 metre fence all the
way up to second that is not a natural
feature I request that you reject this
unwarranted variation on the site catch
the Barnes his I think I've been to this
site but I wasn't cure in the respect
that I found the church there well I was
going to ask what are the fishing lawns
the church then the site then the
fishing lodges goes down is that correct
Castle Barnes if you look at the picture
in front of you which is actually not of
thee this is the refused application you
will see at the top of the picture a red
line marking the extent of the site that
is the start of the embankment created
by the quarry for Macquarie operations
which ceased back in the 60s I think and
the fish lodges are immediately at the
bottom of that cliff
and there are 21 of them and they do
sorry
any other questions
decided question casket how long has the
permission for fishing lodges being
granted how many years ago the fishing
lodges were approval was obtained by a
previous owner the current owner I don't
want to go into certain personal details
if you don't mind mr. chairman that's
for you the personal and the current
owner has been doing significant words
would you actually see on that
photograph if you go you see the blue
writing which says I can't quite Lisa
really says here but there is at the top
of the screen more blue writing on what
looks like a mudslide might to Paul yeah
if you say so I think it just might
appall yes
motor pool he has been filling because
it's been too deep foot to be any
environmental use for a for fish but
also for any other investments rather so
here's been importing with full
authorized plan admission from this
council and Orange County Council to
fill that Lake to improve the quality of
it is own as a feature he's about to do
the same to the lake on the top
left-hand corner and I think that
application has also gone through those
works he's doing first there for the
work on the fishing lodges he needs to
do after he's actually got vomit that's
right you just how long is a permission
bin next sample I think it's yes okay
thank you any any further questions
well interesting device so far we'll
move on to points of clarification
Harvey points for the case officer I've
got a couple yeah obviously it's been
moving forward 10 meters and you were
saying that's full of geotechnical
reasons yes Chet as you can see between
the tiers come forth ten millions from
the embankment which change the cattle
you know where the slope starts from the
pit bulls Lakes the African I stated
that was close geotechnical survey was
undertaken as part of this application
and that's the reason why it's hard to
come forward ten meters chairman I think
the applicant appears to recognize the
shortcomings of this application and
councillor kettle but effectively done
the points of clarification at the
moment sorry still in the points of
clarification sorry we're still on the
points of clarification one
clarification points of clarification on
the debate yet texture Barnes this fence
did sort of the height is because of
environmental health is that right it's
been increased not entirely
environmental health they recommend
between two point six and three point
six meters the height was recommended to
stop any visual and further visual
impact into the site I am eating my
officers report the acoustic barrier
certain a
even feature to the area but it has been
conditioned on the previous report so
that's the reason why we recommended it
parish council mentioned there's some
query between conditions through in
conditions right
apologies condition 8 doesn't mention my
place in the HVAC units or the corner to
pre plans on the roof of any factory and
they shall be not mounted where if you
look at the brief plans they should be
mounted on the side of the elevations if
approved so as a word and that word can
I just clarify counselor kettle has
referred to the refused application
being determined by Planning Committee
in fact it was a refusal under delegated
authority fine we'll move on to the
debate now who would not just up case
Lipari thank you well if nobody else
wants to start first I will I can
remember sitting on the first
application for the eight units and I
can remember it being very finely
balanced decision but one of the key
factors was the fact that the containers
were set so far back and there were only
eight in number from my perspective and
having heard what we've heard this
evening I feel this is a case of over
development to the site and I think
there is an impact on the immunity of
neighboring communities and I cannot
support this application
cansu st. yes right I mean the debate
now thank you
that's most kind it seems to me that the
applicant has recognized some of the
shortcomings but effectively if you look
at councilor kettles presentation
he mentioned cs5 and cs9 I think the
important policy here is cs5 and that
requires us to make certain that any
development is compatible with its
surroundings and neighboring facilities
and this proposal clearly is not it is
an industrial application and I feel
that the applicant has looked at a
suitable site for this and I could
understand the need for it but he
effectively has picked the wrong
location and therefore the impact both
in the design of the units and the
proximity of them and the fence to
neighboring uses is all upside down it's
awry and therefore I will agree with
counselor Perry in that I can't support
this variation the snag is we are
between a rock and a hard place because
if we refuse it we are stuck with an
application which was also considered to
be inadequate
I remember the debate and the
representation that I had from councilor
kettle when this originally went through
with all the problems that he identified
at the time for which I was sympathetic
but I don't think he recognized I was
but that's another matter
the the issue was that effectively this
is a bad scheme and effectively I think
we should sort of send it away okay
thank you that's the Barnes I did
actually look for this size and I think
I found it
it's actually it isn't looking at the
map it looks like a quarry everywhere
but if you go to this side there's trees
all the way around
you can actually see the either job to
come indeed I only got it because I went
to the church and might be the Logies
that happened up I couldn't see you I
saw a couple they are right down the
slope and away really from the site so
although I can understand why the
officers are going feel for approval I'm
not happy with the height of the fence
which but if that's what it's got to be
that's got to be there is condition
condition tend to put landscaping
rounded landscaping around it with both
ways so I can understand where the
officers coming from and I don't feel as
inclined to refuses that two members
before me transfer feeling if we're
going to refuse the new application
we've got to do something about the
danger from the current application
that's being approved because of the
units are so near to the edge now
they're separate applications yeah
that's already been approved this is a
variation where we're trying to decide
whether we agree to the very they would
have to come back with another
application that's a variation okay can
we have one meeting please thank you
thank you chair I think this is this is
a tricky one to balance out I didn't sit
on the original committee that approved
the eight units and it must have been
quite a lengthy debate out of thought I
think that the agent laid out very
clearly how they have tried to address
concerns and it's unfortunate that they
weren't able to attend the parish
council meeting but these things happen
but it sounds like they have engaged the
parish council
I think what's tricky is the unique
location given the fact it's a cemetery
and definite people associate with that
and that does need some protection and
consideration
I agree weave counts Lipari that it does
seem like over development given the
fact it's a 50% increase and I think
it's also the amount it's 10 meters
isn't it that the containers have moved
that seems a considerable amount and my
concern as well as the noise
I think the offense is necessary I agree
it's alien to the environment but I also
questioned if it would actually be
adequate to shield out the amount of
noise from the increase in containers so
unfortunately I might be able to support
the officers recommendation okay thank
you any other people want to contribute
to the debate chairman I'm very happy to
propose that we refuse this application
on grounds of over development of the
site and also impact on the neighboring
communities making reference to policy
cs5 that councillors they made reference
to before I bring in a second I just
like to ask Curran to make a commonplace
sure if I can just clarify the
application you're considering before
you in terms of the assessment is the
difference between the original planning
permission and the current that we're
looking at whether the changes or the
changes or the element that you're
you're assessing at the moment in terms
of the acoustic fence when the
application was originally determined
the acoustic fence was there was a
requirement for an acoustic fence
probably we didn't have a position for
it at the time there was a requirement
to debate at the time so we we don't
know where the fence was going to be
positioned it could well be on the on
the boundaries of the
what we do have is a lower acoustic
fence that was that was expected to come
forward what you have now is a clear
defined boundary for the acoustic
fencing so there is a difference and I'd
ask you to take that into consideration
if you're going to if I could just come
back when I talk about overdevelopment
my main concerns is the increased
density of the containers you've gotten
much more the cumulative impact of
having 50% more structures moved further
forward and it's the cumulative impact
of the density which whilst I'm not a
noising expert inevitably it's the
density and the size and the fact that's
had to move further forward in society I
think what we've just heard chairman
identifies a problem that I didn't
mention earlier and that is we're told
what might happen rather than what will
happen if we're going to give approval
to a scheme we've got to know for
certain what the impact will be and can
I remind Karen that the effectively six
months ago we had a major debate in
council about the role of the planning
manager that was supposed to be there to
support what the committee is trying to
achieve rather than steering in a new
direction which I think she's trying to
do long so I don't agree I think Karen
is trying to what were the best
intentions to to advise rather than
steer so I think I disagree with that
right now sure we've had a proposal
we're looking for a second a full up
proposal to refuse the application
can you just confirm the reason I sent
you yep and can we just
if you've got the recent zone but if I'm
clear crackly reasons eyes over to
Vitamin another site and an increase in
the urbanization on the side which is
can be against policy serious arguments
it's not a core strategy you happy lat
catch the party a figure that catch the
st. so you go to the vote while those in
thank you all those in favor of cancer
Paris proposal any abstentions to
committee it resolved to refuse
application 18 / 1 5 4 7 3 thank you
move on to the next item the agenda
next item on the agenda is application
17 / 0 3 0 1 o REM the site address is
lund off Warwick Road chitin we've got
Dale down Barker presenting this
application Thank You Dale
Thank You chairman can I start by
referring members to the update sheet I
refer to it several times as I go
through the presentation but there are a
number of important points on there that
members to read this application has a
complex background so I propose to
expand this presentation a little
perhaps beyond what we would normally do
to give you some context before you hear
from the parish council and from the
applicant outline planning permission
was granted in November 2016 and the
principle of residential development on
this site is therefore accepted the
proposal is a reserved matters
application to deliver 78 dwellings in a
mix that's broadly in line with your
policies and the site is shown here by
the black dot on the sign it's to the
northwest of Kyneton off the warwick
road what road is this one here and
light thorn Road is this one here and
we'll be coming back to those two roads
as we go through the presentation so
edged in red this is the application
site once again Warwick Road here liked
horn Road there what you can also see on
this plan is in cerise perhaps natural
conservation area boundary this two
buildings marked in red and the tree
preservation orders marked in green you
can also see here on the edge of the
site that's the route of the dish reused
railway line and the site boundary is in
red this is the frontage to wory Road
moving on these photographs give you
views from the access point on the
left-hand here looking broadly southeast
towards Kyneton and on the right here
broadly northeast away from Clinton
societies is on the right here and on
the left here this is the this is the
railway bridge you can see here
moving on this we've turned probably 180
degrees to take this photograph looking
directly into the site as you can see
the railway cutting these on the right
the access will be coming in just the
left where this photograph is taken you
can see quite a substantial tree belt
here and you can see all the the
planting and vegetation that exists in
and along the railway cutting you can
also see how the land falls to the
northwest across the site quite steeply
moving on that's a view from the site
looking northwards across open fields
that's a few a further view inside the
site and this is a view from inside the
site looking across to a meadow or an
area that will be retained as meadow for
its ecological value and we'll come back
to that again a little later
finally for further photographs of the
site and its surroundings
nothing specific to say on those when
the outline permission was granted it
was subject to this outline indicative
master plan and subject conditions that
the reserve matters be in general
accordance with this master plan and
what I want members to look at can't see
in pointer what I want members to to see
and we may retain from this plan for for
the later plans when we get further on
into the presentation is that the
roadway runs all the way through to that
point there's a little spur there which
would conceivably allow the road to
continue through the light horn Road at
some future date it doesn't actually do
it it allows for the possibility the
link is an aspiration in the
neighborhood development plan but also
like you to note other characteristics
for comparison and I've lost the pointer
again here we are the considerable belt
of planting here
which is the the railway cutting
considerable planting here the meadow
here which is being retained for its
ecological value further open space here
and all the way around the edge of the
site terminating in a community orchard
at this point here according to the
application there's something like 65%
of the site is is open space which is an
unusually high amount moving on this is
the application as originally submitted
revision C of the layout plan it's only
an extract from it but it's showing you
how this is the roadway into the site
and if you remember on the illustrative
master plan it went through to that
point there I hope you can see my
pointer and it no longer does so that
was revision C with no potential to link
through to light on Road but in other
respects it was in general accordance
and possibly capable of approval subject
to negotiations we've been through a
number of variations which brings us to
revision t revision T as the roadway
running through the site actually beyond
the point shown on the outline master
plan to the very edge of the site mmm
excuse me it also shows the road I don't
know whether you can see it but it also
shows the road as 6.1 metres in width
with 2 litre 2 meter foot ways that
arrangement was negotiated in order to
satisfy the aspirations of the parish
council to provide a link through
however the local highway authority
wouldn't accept that design of Road they
wouldn't agree to adopt it and they
would object on highway safety grounds
because it's too wide to serve this sort
of residential development so we go on
to revision you
the 21st version of the plan which was
received on Monday and it's intended to
address the concerns of the parish
council it makes provision for extension
here was seating in larger detail later
makes provision for extension across the
meadow the road is reduced to five and a
half meters wide and the local highway
authority have agreed that they would
adopt this layout the foot way on the
south side of the road this one here is
oversized but 2.6 meters which will
allow for the road to be widened at some
future date to 6.1 meters should there
be a change of circumstances which will
allow if necessary the road to be six
point one meters throughout - to form
the link through to light Horn Road and
if you look at the the update sheet you
will see what the highway authorities
comments are on that they've been
summarized by me for simplicity but that
sums them up in other respects this
layout is in general accordance with the
outline master plan the open space the
planting the orchard the shape of the
housing layout the hedges you remember
you saw in the photographs the hedge
running across the site is that one
there this is where the the root of the
old railway was all of that is retained
exactly as envisaged in the master plan
so it very closely reflects the master
plan so let's just have a look at a few
details this has been included to show
the access and I've lost the pointer
again this has been included to show the
access from Warwick Road the reason the
access is particularly important it was
agreed at the outline it's exactly what
was expected at the outline but if you
look you can see
lost this pointer there if you look you
can see there that notation there shows
that there will be quite a substantial
embankment to support the road because
of the change in levels I showed you the
gradient the road will need to be built
up in order to gain access to the site
and again we'll come back to that in
just a minute to see what's involved so
this plans included purely and simply to
show you line a and line B it's an
earlier version of the layout but it
shows you where lines a and line B are
taken so that you can see on the next
plan
this is section a and this is where the
land is to be built up for the roadway
this is section being you can see the
impact of the building up is far less
significant so there's going to be
significant building up there for the
access that was all envisage t' and
expected as part of the outline but
nevertheless you need to be aware of it
so moving on this is a central section
of revision you back to revision you
again you can see in some more detail
the amount and layout of the open space
involved I think really there's little
more to say about it than that and on
this one you can clearly see the
potential access through to the the
meadow land there you can clearly see
that all this planting is to be retained
you can clearly see the place-based
provision just quickly to run you
through the house types they're the sort
of things that are being proposed I
don't think there's really very much to
say about them you know perfectly
reasonable house types again an example
of a street scene and a number of house
types so to conclude chair this is a
proposal that is in general accordance
with the master plan it complies with
the outline permission it complies with
the aspirations of the Neighborhood
Development Plan and the
core strategy and the recommendation is
to grant subject to the one additional
condition you can see on your update
sheet thank you check hunker down 21
revisions I and I note the use of the
word serese which I didn't think I'll be
hearing tonight so thank you very much
for that we'll move on to our first
speakers which are counts the prettiest
and cancer Davis from Canton parish
council oh just catch the prettiest ugly
thank you you've got you know the form
that you've got three minutes
good evening Forrest on retirement I
would agree with the officer this is a
fluid and complex application so Jane
but thank you very much mr. chairman
members um thank you for this
opportunity to fully explain our reasons
for objecting to this application the
Parish Council is objecting to the
proposal before you and actually
requesting that the committee defer its
decision until such time as all the
necessary documents can be produced and
considered as the officer said we've
only been receiving these literally
within the last few days and we there
hadn't been time to consider them fully
consider them and consult on them it's
far too early for this matter to be
fully adjudicated and judged by you we
believe for several months we've had
discussions with Morris homes referenced
the provision of a potential link Road
through this development to the light
Horn Road and onward through other
reserved sites eventually to the
southern road this link road would not
been possible in the future if the
original layout of this site had been
maintained the developers Morris homes
have agreed to a six point one meter
road including traffic calming measures
be included in their application with an
amended Laird as explained by the
officer Warren County Council highways
rejected this width and ignored the
wishes of the people of Canton
reluctantly highways have now agreed to
a five point five meter
with a 2.6 meters urge that might
potentially be used for widening in the
future this only came about from
high-level lobbying on the County
Council this would involve additional
costs which could be avoided if the
highways adopted a less obstructive
attitude this link road is a vital
importance to our village the traffic
issues are substantial and will only get
worse over the next few years with GLH
been built and jl are expanding plus we
have all the traffic from the high
school increasing constantly this is our
only way in our only hope of alleviating
these chronic traffic problems our
adopted neighborhood development plan
contains a clear aspiration voted on by
the people of conscience for such a link
the latest compromise suggested by
Warren County Council has only been put
forward in the last few days our
contention therefore that it is too
early to fully and evaluate and agree
this new road layout the Parish Council
would also like to have the opportunity
to agree any planning conditions
pertaining to this development
particularly in relation to the layout
and road with indeed the latest
consultation from Warren County Council
hyo's was only received by the Planning
Office on Friday the 17th of August and
the parish council only has site of the
consultation of Monday of this week we
feel we must be involved in the drafting
of the conditions to protect the
parishes interest the planning officer
has indicated that he could potentially
involve the parish council in this
finally I should make members aware that
because of the critical importance of
this decision this evening the Parish
Council has taken steps to lodge a call
in application with the Secretary of
State thank you
good evening counselor um I just be
interested in your views in the housing
mix when there are no provisions for
open market one-bed dwellings and an
over provision of three bed Wellings I'd
just be interested to know how that fits
with your neighborhood plan and the
demand in kind term we've got a lot of
development in Kyneton as I'm sure you
appreciate looking at the house in mix
we had no terrible objections to be
quite honest with you because we for
most two provisions on affordable and
open market being fulfilled by other it
wasn't really an issue for us because I
was involved with opportunity but what
concerns me is this seems to be the
second application we've had tonight
where we've had detailed we got a
problem what I'm saying
can we yep can we just go cuz I know
we've got a question for you guys the
pretty okay well on this particular
application we've been treated with a an
issue is can we wait till all the
documentation is in place that's what
the parish counselor is saying which in
first but effectively an awful lot of
material is coming through very late and
there hasn't been time to consider it so
your answer that yes will pretty start I
think you've got a basis because I do
agree with counselors ain't a lot of the
documents were changed very late we've
had very little time to consider and
consult on them particularly in relation
to the highways and the changing of the
road layout and narrowing it so I do
support what kind of Saint
thank you I was gonna what documentation
does he need and when should that come
out and when should we as a planning
authority have proper time to consider
it rather than bringing it in on an
update sheet nothing I think well we
discussed that as well as point and
points for clarification later as well
hope you weren't down yeah thank you and
he gets the bonds I can just about see
like a bypass and because they've cut
the end up where these special bonds is
this part for the application about the
bypass is this actually before part of
your life that's if you want to put
that's why yes thank you right transfer
bonds yes
it was a link road and it certainly was
in our neighborhood plan it takes in
this link road it goes on light on road
and then there are two reserve sites
with two oceans developers are
interested in yeah I think I've
indicated they would accommodate us
again yeah I think you answered the
question all of us Christian what do you
think someone actually say about the
link road in the aspiration it was it
mostly for that place whilst the
examiner was sympathetic to us we
couldn't put it in as a policy okay yeah
that sites we could put it in as an
aspiration widely held and voted on
aspiration by the people that's fine
thank you yes that's very clear AB that
answered question counts the bonds any
other questions Thank You counsel
prettiest thank you very much
and we have Kevin Pearson place Thank
You mr. Pearson
Thank You mr. chairman Thank You mr.
chairman
good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is Kevin Pearson and I am the
design and planning director for Maurice
Holmes Midlands Limited Maurice Holmes
is very pleased to be able to bring this
site forward and we have Lee I used
extensively with your planning officers
and under highways officers of
Warwickshire County Council to achieve a
scheme that is supported and can
therefore be recommended for approval
this evening we've made many adjustments
as you just seen to our scheme and
changes during the reserved matters
planning process particularly to address
concerns have a mix of dwelling types
and sizes dispersion of affordable
dwellings and the redesign of the
eastern end of the scheme to achieve a
better urban design and flowing form of
development leading out to the important
natural meadow area beyond the developed
part of the site this redesign of the
eastern end of the site was offered in
direct response to the aspirations of
Kyneton parish council for an open-ended
development in consultation with
warranty highways
we've also provided a wider highway
corridor through the scheme again to
respond to the wishes of the parish
council but in a way that is acceptable
to highways these changes are all
reflected in the latest lay others
before you this evening revision you
wear any requested changes do not
conflict with the requirements of your
officers and those of county highways we
have made them in the interest of
cooperation good planning and delivering
a better scheme the resultant
development is therefore safe and well
designed and provides a design that is
technically acceptable and capable of
future adoption the scheme is compliant
with all policy requirements of both
Stratford district and war official
County Council's as well as complying
with the requirements of the approved
outline planning permission for all
these reasons we're pleased to have
received support from your planning
officers and those of county highways as
we have designed our scheme and an
inclusive and cooperative way so that
all legitimate and deliverable
requirements have been met we therefore
hope that committee this evening will
feel able to follow your
Foundation and granters reserved mutters
approval and we very much look forward
to delivering this important new
development a kind - Thank You mr.
person thank you very much and now we'll
move on to our ward member accounts the
mills even against males how are you
today
I'm fine Thank You mr. chair
good good it's good to see you all okay
far on well good evening committee mr.
chairman
it's quite simple kinds and page count
is seeking to establish for the future a
possible link from the Morris home
development to the potential reserve
sites across from Whitehall Road this
will in turn relieve neither the traffic
from these new developments away from
the center of the village of kinds at
the present time Kyneton has a massive
traffic issues and if a potential link
road is not put in place now then in the
future the village may become gridlocked
we may be looking to the future but now
is the time to try and alleviate and
minimize the problems of traffic
pollution for a village that is now
growing quite rapidly in addition the
manual for streets which is which is
government and County recommended advice
encourages such connectivity through and
between housing development to avoid
isolated spoke estates on the edge of
settlements it states at section two
point five point nine playing in
highways authority should require
developers to provide for future
connections when further expansion is a
part of the possibility more homes have
agreed to a six point one meter wide
road with traffic calming measures but I
fear highways are obstructing this with
no clear understanding
that traffic is using Kyneton the county
has confirmed that there was support for
the original six point one meter road
just to remind you the six point one
meter road was specifically set out in
the I am planning permission this is
reserved matters application with the
main access road arrangements already
approved by this committee in the
outline permission this proposal from
frontier is for a five point five meter
access road appears to have crept under
the radar there seem to be had been some
confusion between developer and the
highways are throw it to be of what
about what is required we already have
an increase in traffic of five percent
through the village and along the
Warrick Road and to echo the words from
the chairman of the parish counts of
David Gosselin I'm sure he's watching
tonight although he's away on the
holiday is to lose this opportunity will
be economic madness as his future link
Road will be at the developers cost are
not worried should County Council cost
what is the point of Morris homes
footing in finite point five meter wide
Road who needs a habit widened at a
future date the chiton Neighborhood
Development Plan is clear in his
aspirations for link road and to ignore
the MDP will be an absolute travesty and
render it useless
please tell me committee what is the
point of NDP so they are now being
ignored in my opinion DP should be
sacrosanct in summary one Maurice homes
have agreed to a six point one meter
wide road why should counter cannot had
no objection to the six point one meter
wide road when approved as an outline
matter three a link road is vital when
the reserve sites come forward in the
future years and four if we do not act
now to try and make the best of the
traffic problems that were embedded in
met inevitably come with rapidly
increase in the size of kinds and we as
a district council will be doing great
disservice to the future residents of
Clinton my I do not to grant this
application enterprise inform Thank You
mr. chair
thank you catch the mouse any questions
for the ward member no thank you can
smell up lightly there didn't I thank
you obviously said it all thank you they
will move on two points of clarification
catch the bonds in case of rain chairman
I would I would have to check to know to
be quite honest but I think the critic
know the critical answer here is that at
the outline stage no one was agreeing
any road dimensions whatsoever the local
highway authority will always deal with
that post planning the points cases
ain't does that mean to the councillor
brains question if the parish council
have seen no documents no documents that
should have been prepared have been
prepared it seems that one's got a big
mm counselor I have another got the
question for me please sorry I didn't
understand the question I'm sorry please
rephrase let me have it let me let me
see if I can answer what might have been
the question counselor let me see if I
can answer what might have been the
question we need to know precisely now
if from what the parish council says
that the documentation or information
was coming out on the 17th of August
last week
clearly that needs to be formally
documented
for us in my view to make a decision so
I'm trying to sort of see what
clarification there might be what sort
of documents are floating about that
might need to come to us and the parish
council in order to be certain about
this application chairman there are no
documents that the Parish Council should
need to see that have not been provided
to the Parish Council the latest plan
was provided to them on Monday that's
three days ago I'm well aware that that
is far shorter than would normally be
provided but the reason for that is
because this has been an ongoing process
of the developer trying to to square the
circle that is the local highway
authority who won't agree to a six point
one metre road and the Parish Council
who want a six point one meter Road and
the developer who is trying to find
something that we can bring in front of
members for approval members are well
known for not wanting to go against the
advice of the local highway authority so
we wouldn't dream of bringing an
application to you where the local my
authority couldn't support it and the
parish council are very clear and their
aspiration for a road but the examiner
in the local in the Neighborhood
Development Plan was very clear that the
plan does not put for with robust
evidence either for its need or its
delivery and therefore it can only be an
aspiration and as it's only an
aspiration officers felt that it was
appropriate to bring it in front of you
as a potential link that can be resolved
another day we can't resolve this at
this stage thank you no okay so the
brain it's necessary for a parish
council to have seven days clear notes
of a meeting to discuss new information
do you consider that three days is
sufficient to do that
as as I've explained the amendments were
made in order to satisfy the parish
council to meet their aspirations and
therefore it was expected that the
parish council could meet and could
comment they haven't done so I should
add that part of those negotiations
involve council a second at the county
council the parish were not represented
in those meetings the parish did you
indicate but on campus I would just like
some clarification Dale if you wouldn't
mind as to what is the normal
recommended time scale for amended plans
that are pushed out to parish councils
and also the ward member as a policy
from the planning committee the planning
department where applications have been
through many into iterations as this one
has we often reduce the amount of time
never to three days admittedly but we
often reduce the amount of time to 7 or
10 days as I said it in this instance
because of the close involvement in the
parish council and the direct intention
to provide what the parish council were
seeking to achieve we felt that a
three-day period could be enough if
members don't feel it is enough that
we've delivered exactly what the parish
council wanted then obviously you won't
want to consider deferring as requested
by the parish council against the bonds
am i right in assuming that the parish
council 16.1 the county council are
given from 0.1 if you like but the
builders have agreed to or why pavements
to be 6.1 at some time am I correct in
that because it just looked at me as
though the builders bending over
backwards for them
the locals but it's the candy cancel its
messing it up
am i right through the footpath will
allow a wider Road as a later date if
required I think the parish council
would have to answer for itself over
what with the it thinks is is reasonable
my understanding is that the parish
council want a link road I don't think
they're too fixated on the width of it
as I said the parish council will have
to answer that for themselves the local
highway authority have made it very
clear that they will not accept 6.1 the
developer has offered 6.1 but the local
highway authority will not adopt it and
will come to you with highway objections
if 6.1 is proposed so the compromise
that was worked out last week was that a
five point five meter road which the
local highway will occur will accept
which is their normal requirement is
offered with the potential to widen a
future date if the parish council can
bring together for the link it needs to
progress several second is that catch
the berry deferral deferral commit no
thank you we're going to defer all sorry
visitor shop that committee resolves to
defer item 17 0 3 0 1 o REM
right when they've swiftly on to the
next item agenda which is agenda item
number 6 TP o / 0 6 6 / 0 0 7 London
vicarage read the rest of 1 hour winds
cottages victory trade and Upton on the
hill and the percentage opposite if Joe
Brooke Thank You chair the application
is on that Vicki Rose West Irian sky is
napped on the hill for a tree
preservation order sycamore tree at
Vicky's Rose nap salon Hill was located
at the rear two-foot way on a small Bank
man as you can see on the indicated map
on the screen these are views of the
sycamore looking onto it a TPO who was
served following the currents will
receive an information that a sycamore
located at Vicarage Road map Tunnel Hill
was proposed to be proven by the
contractors working on path of an
adjacent resident the trees of Sycamore
approximately 60 years old and stands on
small Bank to the rear the foot way the
tree is not in ownership of Warren
County Council and the land on which the
tree is located it is not registered
within a Land Registry as well the
adjacent neighbor Alaska at legs Kotori
did not own the tree but proposed to
undertake a nabokov agricultural work to
the tree the reduction works proposed
were deemed to be detrimental to the
aesthetics of the tree and also to the
health of the tree they would have
resulted in a tree of the reduced
immunity value the tree is 16 meters
high the crown spread is 15 meters the
tree is 11 meters the adjacent property
at last gets as shown on the plan and is
located at a higher level than the set
property these views of the tree to the
consign feast on the foot way on Victory
Road Laska property is in the background
looking southeast from Vickie's Road you
can see the Sycamore and on the public
highway looking northeast along Victory
Road is ever viewed of the Sycamore as
well as last
property on one our winners cottage the
Sycamore located on a bank
Jason's he asked his driveway to the
garages and properties to the northeast
and east one Owens cottage is in the
background and front garden wall of
Alaska in the foreground looking
southeast from the foot way with the
property that Alaska is in the
background of the tree and that is the
end of the presentation thank you sir
sorry check it is recommended that
members decided to choose confirm with
the order of modification the reason
being is there has been noted that there
has been a spelling error in the title
and the group references and coordinate
thank you tonight I'm just like taking
this opportunity to send our best wishes
to catch the Williams who's know very
well so I'm sure the committee will
agree that we do that
thank you guys the van sir any points of
clarification
Joseph Hilden no one comes forward it
automatically is dealt not on tree
preservation orders thank you we did
pretty well before there's anybody
second nuts cancer brain all those in
favor
Thank You Council resolves to confirm
the order with modification right we'll
move on to our next item which is 18 / 2
0 1 4 7 0 very lung to the north of wash
Road West
Mastan dolls prize in Austin and Jerry's
presenting again thank you Jeff really
when you are
thanks Jeff the applications for a
variation application to the land of
north of Welsh Road Marcin dolls
probably as of Marsden as you can see on
the plan on the screen where it is
located in open countryside prize
masters to South East and Marcin doles
is located to the south southwest this
is a redline boundary of an aerial view
of the site that's in question the site
benefits from a recent permission for
the erection of a stable block a ménage
the approved a wood block contains space
for 11 horses this was approved under
application reference 1601 364 such full
is not yet been implemented this
application seeks to remove condition
for of the applet of the previous
planning permission to enable the
stables to use for commercial that our
DIY livery purposes the application is
comforted by a statement from the
African which explains background and
information about proposed use this is a
block time from the 2016 application
which indicates whether stable block and
the monarch will be implemented on the
site
these are elevations he approved stay
will block further elevations on the
East elevation and sections on the west
elevations and this is a legal block
plan a floor plan of the approval a
stable block indicating the stables and
the my large area and the size to which
they have been approved
these are photos of the area these are
the two photos from the adjacent Road
and presently the site is gated by metal
gateway across the Ark's this way you
can see in the bottom photo these are
photos taken when the application from
the previous application was approved
off the site as you can see there is an
area of highest landing area which was
witnessed on the aerial photograph and
there is some containers and storage and
uses on the side these are open views of
the open field of the site where the
Lachlan with a stable block would be
developed and that is the end of the
presentation recommendation is for
approval
following a removal of condition for
subject to the following condition as a
number in which is delegated to officers
Thank You Jo now we've got a speaker
we've got a speaker so we'll move on to
our first speaker
she's Cathal Watson you've got three
minutes you've got plenty of time take
your time three minutes and we won't
bite um good evening my name is cath
Watson and I'm the applicant I just
wanted to take the opportunity to
explain the proposals and my background
I have worked with horses since I was 11
and had my own horse from the age of 15
my father purchased earth at the
application site in July 2017 when it
had already had the planning application
pending by the previous owner for 11
stables
we also own the adjoining land with a
total of 30 acres the planning
permission which was granted for the
previous owner was for private use as a
keen horse woman 11 stable seems
excessive for a private use but it was
granted I know the parish councils
common about the previous owners
intentions however I can assure you I
have no knowledge of her intentions and
I have no connection with her this is my
own separate proposal the main occupant
is and my main occupation is an
administration administrator for a farm
backed I have 150 sheep and three horses
my proposal is to run a DIY livery
whilst keeping my own horses there is
plenty of opportunity to ride with to
bridle ways from our field next to the
application site one - price Hardwick
and the other to Haledon this
application simply seeks to allow the
approved stables to be used for live
purposes there are a number of
advantages of DIY deliveries for example
the company over the horse owners /
riders the safety aspect of having other
people around when you are with the
horses and riding and the ability of
other horse owners to check on your
horses I understand the key issues in
this application to be an assessment as
to why the council previously condition
the site to be use of private equestrian
purposes the reason for the condition
was to allow an assessment of the impact
on residential amenity and traffic
generation and highway safety I
commissioned a highways consultant to
assess the impact on the local roads
they concluded the scale of the traffic
generator
generated by this proposed application
for the removal of the private
restriction is minimal and would have an
in this an indiscernible impact on the
roads serving the local and wider area
what she can see counts all highways
raised no objection in terms of the
impact on residential amenity there are
no near neighbors to be affected and
whether there are 11 horses for private
use or 11 horses for livery use there is
ultimately no greater impact I am it's a
paragraph next say I just say thank you
for listening
cats advance I think we'll have you only
was that a question for the applicant
cats of ants so I didn't quite hear what
you said originally good evening
given the fact it'll be DIY livery how
will you be able to manage the people to
be sure that they abide by the rules and
respect the the neighborhood and the
traffic issues that potentially could
arise if it's DIY what level of control
will you have over them um well they on
the previous plan application they've
been approved for 20 car parking spaces
on the hard standing obviously and that
would fully compensate for the amount of
forces that were there there there would
be contracts with DIY liveries and if
you know they weren't didn't abide by
the rules then the contract would be
terminated Thank You st. Catherine yes
we are not exactly looking at the local
economy of the emerging city of Aston
dollars only but effectively I wasn't on
the committee at the time when the
original application was approved and
there is comment in our report papers
that it was originally intended as a
commercial activity rather than a
private main harsh because individuals
that I know from past experience
wouldn't normally 11 horses that house
an exercise but you argue that the
county council are happy with the
traffic arrangements so and I can't see
there's a major problem there but would
you like to sort of comment on this
dilemma we seem to be in where as
effectively you're asking us to sort of
say you know release me from this
condition then I can operate it as I
intended
and yes well obviously we had nothing to
do with the plan information that went
in originally that was on the land when
we bought it and the it just seems to
make use of the planning permission
which was already approved I wouldn't be
able to do that for personal use there's
no way I could afford 11 horses
unfortunately and so to grasp
opportunity it would have to be through
delivery mm-hmm
I mean to me this is a rural activity
and we should be encouraged but so if
you think but we need to be certain yeah
thank you chairman thank you no no
further questions ready to go Katherine
thank you very much
right then any points of clarification
any comments any proposals O'Donnell can
I just say I think that Katherine
presented really clearly there and it's
so positive to see someone seizing an
opportunity for a nice rural enterprise
at a young age he's got a thorough
background in it so I'd be delighted to
support the proposal to grant permission
yeah vote then Casey bonds are you
indicating you want to go to vote all
those in favor committee resolves to
grant application 18 0 1 4 7 0 very with
the amended recommendation and the
updates it thank you and there's no
urgent business so I now declare the
meeting closed